et avec nous pour le débat de ce club
qui sera consacré au projet d'autoroute
entre Castres et Toulouse qui vise à
désenclaver une partie du Tarn et
réduire le temps de trajet soutenu par
une grande partie des élus locaux il est
contesté notamment sur le plan
environnemental on va en débattre hier
le ministre des Transports Clément
Beaune a confirmé le début des travaux
mais à déclaré qu'il allait demander des
améliorations environnementales et pour
en débat justement Philippe bonne
Carrère bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sénateurs sont triste du Tarn vous
défendez ce projet on va évidemment en
parler avec vous Thomas dessus bonjour
sénateur écologiste du Rhône vous êtes
vous opposé à ce projet vous étiez
d'ailleurs la mobilisation des opposants
il y a quelques jours on va voir tout ça
Anthony Cortez bonjour merci d'être là
vous êtes journaliste à Marianne auteur
de ce livre qu'on va voir l'affrontement
qui vient de l'éco-résistance à
l'écoterrorisme c'est votre livre qu'on
voit s'afficher on va évidemment
débattre de ce projet d'abord pour que
tout le monde comprenne bien Mathias on
va voir avec vous en quoi consiste ce
projet d'autoroute à 69 alors c'est un
projet qui a été lancé il y a bientôt 30
ans un objectif affiché désenclaver
toute la moitié sud du département du
Tarn en reliant la 68 entre Toulouse et
Albi à la rocade Castres un projet jugé
d'utilité publique depuis 2018 alors
l'axe est long de 53 km c'est des
tronçons de 2 x 2 voies et un axe qui
pourrait faire gagner 25 à 35 minutes
selon les horaires de circulation Oriane
et quels sont les chiffres mis en avant
par les opposants au projet Mathias
alors l'opposition au projet n'est pas
tant économique écologique c'est donc le
coût environnemental du projet qui est
décrié 420 hectares nécessaires qui
seraient imperméabilisés dont 316 de
surfaces agricoles 200 arbres
d'alignement dont de grands platanes
patrimoniaux qui devront être coupés
soit pratiquement très hectares de zones
boisées pour le coup économique quand
même rapidement on parle d'un projet
autour de 530 millions d'euros dont 23
millions de subventions publiques et la
donnée qui intéressera les
automobilistes le prix du péage 8, 37 €
l'aller-retour et voilà c'est beaucoup
plus clair on va voir maintenant ce
qu'il en est sur place les premiers
travaux ont débuté les opposants des
noms c'est un projet anachronique à
contre-temps des préoccupations
environnementales ils ont organisé une
manifestation il y a quelques jours je
n'attends du priez et audreytaz les ont
suivi regarde
une fois terminé l'autoroute devrait
passer ici en plein milieu de ce terrain
agricole c'est pour cela que les
opposants à la future à 69 on choisit de
s'y réunir ce jour-là ils sont plus de
5000 des particuliers des politiques des
familles pour tenter de siffler la fin
du projet je suis l'homme parce que je
pense que c'est vraiment un projet qui
est complètement absurde qui inutile et
si on a besoin de d'infrastructures
c'est clairement pas d'autoroute avec
les enjeux de transition de la mobilité
de notre impact sur l'environnement les
gaz à effet de serre l'impact sur la
biodiversité construire une autoroute va
à contresens de ce qui doit être fait
aujourd'hui quoi c'est le symbole de ce
qui tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire cela
fait plus de 40 ans que cette autoroute
est dans les cartons elle doit permettre
de relier Castres à Toulouse pour
désenclaver le sud du Tarn un projet
accéléré ces dernières années
l'autoroute a été déclarée d'utilité
publique Sabine mousson est la mère de
telatte 500 habitants situés sur le
qu'on a mis un petit mot d'accueil pour
le concessionnaire atoscar c'est son nom
dehors à 69 à 69 non les gens ils vont
klaxon
on le voit beaucoup au campement de
vendinnes il y a beaucoup de gens qui
claquentent vous voyez car pour te latte
la vie paisible ne sera plus jamais
comme avant et pour s'en rendre compte
il faut prendre de la hauteur
l'autoroute en rouge passera au milieu
du village avec la partie du village qui
est en bas là et qui du coup va faire
que notre village va être coupé en deux
carrément quoi avec un pont futur pour
pour rejoindre le village quoi c'est
plus du tout le même village ah non non
on va devenir un village en bord
d'autoroute quoi alors qu'ici on est
dans une vallée fertile avec un cadre de
vie quand même très agréable vous voyez
qui disparaîtra ça c'est sûr elle est
d'autant plus amère que l'autoroute
passera en parallèle et à quelques
mètres de la nationale
nous la retrouvons le jour de la
manifestation il y a plein de monde moi
j'ai jamais vu autant de mobiliser
contre l'autoroute
après toutes ces années où on a du mal à
être entendus en tout cas écoutez on
était entendu pas écouter c'est de voir
autant de monde se mobiliser pour ce
projet c'est chouette je pense qu'on
peut être dans un moment de bascule en
tout cas si on a un c'est maintenant
manifestants et lui viennent de toute la
France comme Thomas do su qui est
pourtant sénateur du Rhône à 400 km de
là contre ces projets routiers ici comme
ailleurs c'est important de les mener
nous nous on défend un moratoire sur ce
projet route et c'est des projets qui
sont anachroniques partout ici à Rouen
dans le Chablais moi je viens de Lyon
donc le projet entre Saint-Étienne et
Lyon la 45 s'est arrêtée parce qu'il y a
une mobilisation phénoménale des gens
qui habitent le territoire et donc ce
qu'on ce que je vois ici ça ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu'on a vécu sur la 45
entre Lyon et Saint-Étienne un film
espoir pour les manifestants Clément
Beaune le ministre des Transports promet
de réexaminer un certain nombre de
projet s routiers avant l'été et la 69
en fait partie
on va évidemment y venir dans quelques
minutes on a entendu les opposants
Philippins Carrère vous vous défendez ce
projet pourquoi
le sud du Tarn est en particulier la
zone 15-13 mazametaine est une zone
magnifique qui a une histoire
industrielle exceptionnelle qui s'est
disparu avec l'effondrement des filières
textile c'est des pays c'est un pays où
les gens sont entreprenants et qui ne
peut que réussir et qui ne demande qu'à
réussir si les désenclavé la première
élément important c'est de permettre à
ce territoire à ses habitants de vivre
et se développer et le deuxième élément
c'est que nous sommes sur un secteur
géographique si Monsieur dossier a
regardé un peu autour de lui qui apporte
déjà énormément l'environnement de notre
pays les monts de la Caune c'est de
l'eau c'est des forêts ce sont des
éoliennes la Montagne Noire qui bordent
ce projet autoroutier c'est un énorme
château d'eau il y a pas de hasard
siriké Pierre Paul Riquet a réalisé le
Canal du Midi à partir de cet
alimentation à nos donc vous êtes sur un
contraire enclavé qui ne demande qu'à se
développer qui ne veut surtout pas être
une réserve d'indien et qui apporte déjà
beaucoup à l'environnement de notre pays
et je vous confirme bien volontiers le
soutien quasi unanime de tous les
acteurs sociaux économiques et
politiques du territoire laissez-nous
vivre et laissez-nous nous développer
comme nous le souhaitons et comme nos
concitoyens on me semble-t-il le droit
légitime de pouvoir l'envisager vous
entendez ces arguments Thomas dessus on
l'a vu vous êtes allés manifester vous
avec les opposants sur la nécessité de
développement économique bien sûr mais
moi je conteste l'idée qu'une autoroute
est un outil de développement économique
pour un territoire l'autoroute c'est un
phénomène qu'on connaît partout c'est à
dire que ça va en réalité renforcer la
place centrale de Toulouse par rapport à
Castres ça va renforcer la
métropolisation c'est à dire que ça va
développer du pendulaire des
déplacements pendulaires de travailleurs
de Toulouse qui vont s'installer dans
des endroits où effectivement le foncier
est un peu moins cher que aux abords de
Toulouse et donc on va renforcer un mode
de développement économique qui va
absorber en réalité les énergies autour
de la ville de Toulouse ensuite moi
j'entends le laisser nous vivre il y a
pas de moi je suis pas là pour faire de
l'ingérence sur un territoire mais par
contre en réalité le laisser nous vivre
c'est aussi laisser une planète
habitable et la France a pris un centre
d'engagement climatique en s'attendent
d'engagement en termes de mobilité qui
ne sont pas respectées avec ce genre de
projet qui sont qui ont été développés
dans une conception économique d'il y a
30 ans mais qu'aujourd'hui n'intègre pas
un certain nombre de contraintes
écologiques que la France a signé on a
plusieurs engagements la stratégie
nationale bas carbone l'engagement
feature FIFA et au niveau européen le
zan on a beaucoup de d'engagements que
la France a pris au niveau national et
qui ne sont plus respectés par ce genre
de projet ce projet il n'est pas unique
en France il y en a plusieurs il y avait
il y a 7 ou 8 projets d'auto encore en
France il y a une cinquantaine de
projets routiers qui sont contestés et
cette logique là elle date d'une période
où on ne prenait pas en compte nos
limites planétaires c'est pas pour rien
que au moment de cette mobilisation
Christophe Cassou était là Christophe
Cassou c'est à des auteurs produits GIEC
un rapport qui est sorti il y a à peine
un mois qui nous dit que ce il est venu
nous dire que ce mode d'infrastructure
ce mode de développement n'est plus
soutenable ne rentre en contradiction
totale avec les engagements qu'on prend
d'une part c'est un projet qui est
assorti de garantie environnementale
très importante je vais pas vous ennuyer
avec les hectares de plantation
supplémentaires qui vont être réalisées
d'arbres des
liaisons pour la petite faune comme la
grande fan de mes chevaux redis chers
collègues que vous êtes sur un secteur
géographique qui apporte beaucoup à
l'environnement si vous aviez regardé un
petit peu au dessus de votre tête vous
auriez vu le parc régional du Hollande
doc 300 éoliennes la contribution ce
territoire au développement durable est
important dans le développement durable
il y a les deux éléments il y a durable
il y a des vélos le bassin sud du Tarn
avec son histoire industriel avec un
créativité de ses habitants demande à
pouvoir évoluer dernier élément votre
propos est celui d'un élu du Rhône j'ai
beaucoup d'estime pour la métropole
lyonnaise comme pour les grandes villes
en général mais il faut que vous
entendiez qu'il y a des territoires en
particulier au fond de l'Occitanie qui
n'ont pas connu le désenclavement qui
n'ont pas les infrastructures de la
région lyonnaise même un autre échelle
qui ont encore besoin d'être désenclavé
nous ne disons pas que l'autoroute
suffit assurer le développement ce dont
nous sommes par contre certains c'est
que l'absence de d'autoroute freine
considérablement notre développement
c'est une condition autrement dit qui
est nécessaire mais dont nous prétendons
pas que les suffisante au développement
mais la population a besoin de ce
développement est en soutien très fort
de ce projet
les opposants au projets locaux pas
c'est pas moi avec ma vision du Rhône
même si le Rhône n'est pas qu'une que la
métropole lyonnaise c'est un territoire
aussi rural et qui est voisin avec des
territoires beaucoup plus enclavés je
pense à l'Ardèche par exemple que le
castre ce projet les opposants donc
propose des alternatives une
alternatives notamment la
l'élargissement ou au moins la mise au
norme de la de la RN 126 ou le
développement d'infrastructure
ferroviaire on peut désenclaver
autrement qui consommerait beaucoup
moins de terres agricoles évidemment et
donc vous vous dites si vous aviez levé
les yeux etc j'ai levé les yeux c'est
une terre magnifique il y a il y a aucun
problème avec ça
le tracé de la manifestation qu'on a
vécu passait à côté par exemple de d'un
espace de nidification de Héron
pique-beeu c'est-à-dire une espèce
protégée il y a une centaine d'espèces
protégées l'autorité environnementale a
contesté la pertinence du projet en tout
cas elle a mis beaucoup de réserves le
conseil
[Musique]
6200 contributions ce qui est un chiffre
d'ampleur tout de même pour une enquête
publique de ce type là et 90% 5800
contributions sont défavorables alors je
sais bien que les opposants disent oui
ce sont toujours les mêmes qui sont
mobilisent mais tout de même il y a eu
une parole publique il y a une prise de
position de la population avec un
certain nombre d'élus locaux également
et c'est ce qu'on entend quand on est
sur le terrain du côté des militants
c'est que c'est dommage que le dialogue
ne soit pas ouvert et qu'il y ait un
passage en force avec un projet vieux de
plusieurs décennies et en contradiction
là je vous rejoins avec les objectifs et
les enjeux actuels et quand je parle
d'objectif je pense notamment à
l'objectif zéro artificialisation des
sols et là très clairement on est sur un
projet totalement anachronique
puisque il faut revenir au point de
départ on vous dit aujourd'hui que toute
route ou toute autoroute nouvelle doit
être écarté donc on voit bien que c'est
pas la question du détail du projet pas
plus que l'accompagnement et la vie
aussi des populations il y a des
décennies qui se projetent évoqué il est
inscrit dans une loi il a fait l'objet
de plusieurs décisions purger de tout
recours la quasi-totalité des élus
locaux la totalité élue départementaux
les deux sénateurs le député de la
circonscriptions le département de la
région la chambre des agricultures les
syndicats salariés il y a un soutien
général un dernier point là-dessus la
vraie question posée par mon collègue
elle consiste à dire mais pourquoi vous
n'avez pas envisagé une solution
alternative et financer l'aménagement de
la voie entendez le bien chers collègues
cette idée
n'a jamais été proposé au territoire et
l'indication que vous avez donné et je
vous prenais excuser d'insister
là-dessus profondément erroné pourquoi
cela n'a jamais été possible pour ce
territoire pour avoir vécu tous les
contrats de plans successifs l'ancienne
région Midi-Pyrénées sous la présidence
de Monsieur Malvy avait à financer les
reines exercice Hoche Toulouse nous
sommes une région globalement avec un
gros retard il y a pas eu de plantes
type Bretagne donc Midi-Pyrénées a fait
le choix de Hoche Toulouse de la
traversée du lot de la RN 20 Sud pour
nous relier à Landor et à l'Espagne et
chaque fois la conclusion est le même
lorsqu'il fallait décider des
financements routiers Castres Toulouse
c'est trop gros financièrement on peut
pas le faire donc quand le financera par
concession autoroutière ça a été le cas
pour deux contrats de plans avec
l'arrivée de la région Occitanie et
manelga même scénario avec cette fois ci
l'idée mais non on peut pas le faire on
met tout l'argent sur le ferroviaire
vous vous serez traité par la concession
autoroutière donc ce territoire n'a
jamais eu d'alternative qui lui ait été
offerte autre que le concession
autoroutière donc à un moment donné il
faut bien passer aux actes
et j'ajoute un mot puisqu'on avait
Christophe beitchumi la transition
écologique qui disait que doubler la
nationale c'était encore plus coûteux en
terme d'environnemental ça voulait dire
encore plus d'armes abattus
d'hectares de terrain agricole par
rapport au 400 prévu par la concession
au retour routière donc c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas la réalité
l'enjeu c'est ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire un projet qui a été pensé
il y a des dizaines d'années et qui
aucune alternative n'a été pensée donc
oui mais ça c'est un problème proposé
c'est un problème c'est-à-dire que
depuis les ça fait 30 ans à peu près 22
94 voilà fait 30 ans qu'on réfléchit à
ce projet en 30 ans la France a pris des
engagements on a changé de paradigme on
a on a pris conscience d'un certain
nombre de problèmes notamment développé
par ce genre de projet gène a tenu
compte mais non le projet d'anti
apparaît
on va pas c'est sûr mais là dessus on a
des points de vue complètement
différents je pense que à des projets
autoroutiers maintenant sont à la
chronique tous c'est sur parce que hier
Clément bonnes à réagi aux questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée alors il a rappelé ce que
dit Philippe bancaire que le projet a
fait il y a eu des engagements
contractuels que tous les recours ont
été rejetés qui les soutenu par la
grande majorité des îles locaux mais
quand même il dit qu'il va recevoir le
concessionnaire pour lui demander de
nouveaux engagements des améliorations
sur les aspects environnement tout
savoir sur ça non ça me rassure pas
évidemment on connaît les enfin quand on
s'oppose à ce genre de projet on étudie
beaucoup les arguments souvent de Vinci
ou des concessionnaires de compensations
etc tout ça c'est de la fumisterie ça
n'a jamais eu l'impact ça n'a jamais
réparé les les dommages que ça que ces
projets créent maintenant quand
j'entends que les Mambo nous dire il y a
des engagements contractuels il y en
avait à Notre-Dame-des-Landes aussi on a
quand même pris une décision
d'abandonner ce projet qui avait purgé
un son de recours mais qui est voilà on
peut aussi faire des choix on peut faire
des choix
on a des engagements contractuels
vis-à-vis de l'Europe vis-à-vis l'accord
de Paris c'est un engagement aussi de la
France la possibilité de la parole de la
France qui est en jeu quand on continue
ce mode de développement et qu'on nous
explique que on va trouver des solutions
peut-être à l'avenir pour compenser la
stratégie sur ces sur ces projets là
c'est d'abord éviter de détruire des
éléments naturels ensuite non c'est
d'abord oui éviter ensuite c'est réduire
et ensuite c'est compenser éviter et
réduire on n'a pas fait sur du 12 sur ce
projet
si c'est éviter réduire compensées
largement largement réalisé sur ce
territoire et sur ce projet je retiens
une chose comme en collecte c'est la
notion de parole de l'État dans une
société il y a un cadre sociétal
c'est-à-dire qu'on se met d'accord sur
la manière de prendre des décisions on a
des juridictions qui arbitres tout ceci
à partir du moment où tout ceci a été
fait et respecté il y a bien un moment
où il faut exécuter notre cadre social
ou alors on considère qu'il n'y a plus
aucun cadre notre sociétal et que toutes
les décisions même prises dans les
conditions les plus régulières peuvent
être mises en cause c'est un point sur
lequel la jeune pourrait pas suivre mon
collègue je tiens au respect tout
simplement du cadre qui fait que nous
sommes une société avec notre unités
sur les déclarations de Clément Beaune
d'un côté il acte que les travaux vont
commencer parce que les recours ont été
épuisés puis de l'autre il dit mais
effectivement on va quand même revoir il
faut des améliorations sur les espèces
environnementaux c'est un peu une forme
d'entre-deux la part du gouvernement
on voyait que juste avant la
manifestation il a voulu calmer les
esprits on avait tous scène solide en
tête avec ce risque d'affrontement et de
et de dégâts majeurs donc ça a été bien
accueilli plutôt enfin plutôt bien
accueilli par les militants qui ont dit
pas de violence ça ne sert à rien de se
radicaliser vu que le ministre fait un
pas vers nous on va faire aussi un pas
vers lui mais là voilà il recule
finalement c'était porteur d'espoir
parce qu'on se disait oui il faut revoir
ces projets à Allonnes du de la question
environnementale et du réchauffement
climatique c'était c'était une bonne
chose et finalement on continue à
avancer à marche forcée et ce qui est
malheureusement une habitude du côté du
gouvernement sur ce sur un certain
nombre de projets on l'a vu par exemple
autour des bassines ouais justement un
mot sur la forme de cette manifestation
puisque effectivement c'est une
manifestation qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme sans heur sans violence
contrairement à ce qu'on a vu à
sainte-solini et il y a quelques
semaines comment vous expliquer la
différence entre les deux alors la
différence entre les deux c'est cassaine
Soline le socle de la mobilisation était
portée notamment par les soulèvements de
la terre là à l'inverse c'était un
ensemble de groupes de collectifs locaux
avec une habitude et une tradition
autour du dialogue et et du militantisme
plus institutionnel on va dire on voyait
des groupes comme France Nature
Environnement notamment qui est un
groupe très constructif qui qui tente de
créer de la jurisprudence
environnementale notamment on a vu même
europécologie les Verts et on a vu aussi
extinction rébellion Toulouse qui était
à la manœuvre et qui les jours qui
précédaient la manifestation insister
sur leur vol de ne pas voir de violence
ils ont eu cette formule un petit peu
rigolote qui disait on est plus molky
que boules de pétanque donc voilà ça a
annoncé la couleur et de l'autre côté
voilà on a vu aussi la préfecture être
beaucoup plus mesuré aussi tendre la
main essayer d'organiser la
manifestation avec ses groupes là donc
il y a une vraie responsabilité des deux
côtés c'est peut-être la grande
différence avec cette solide la grande
différence c'est que la manifestation
était autorisée et que effectivement la
préfecture a dialoguer avec les
organisateurs à s'insoli de la
manifestation avait été interdite ils
avaient même mis en garde à vue une
semaine avant Julien Legay un des
organisateurs de la manifestation
précédente donc on avait deux
conceptions du dialogue complètement
différente et ce qu'il faut rappeler
c'est que cette mobilisation elle est
historique c'est 8000 personnes qui sont
venues dans une zone rurale manifestée
leur opposition au projet il venait en
grande partie du territoire et donc il
fallait ça je ne partage pas écoutez
c'est ce que je vais te montrer en tout
cas
et donc ça il faut le rappeler ensuite
la manifestation pas pu se passer comme
ça à Sainte Soline avec du dialogue elle
ça a pas été le cas la réalité c'est que
la plupart des personnes qui étaient là
sont attachées à quelque chose qui
dépasse évidemment la nature uniquement
du projet et qui est une inquiétude
majeure sur la continuer ce mode de
développement économique qui impacte nos
vies et qui impacte l'habitabilité de la
planète enfin je rappelle qu'un quand un
scientifique du GIEC vient exprimer son
attitude sur un projet je pense qu'on
peut l'écouter aussi on va juste être
les bonnes cartes sur le profil de ces
manifestants la manifestation s'est très
bien passée il y a quelques jours vous
vous redoutez que ça ne soit pas le cas
s'il y a d'autres manifestations et que
il y a une forme de durcissement de la
contestation si elles ne sont pas
entendu je me permets pas d'être
l'annonciateur du du pire je pense
effectivement que en toute situation il
fait au privilégier le dialogue et je
redemande aux gens aux autres de voir la
situation dans le cadre global il y a
une population qui a besoin de vivre qui
a besoin de se développer et il y a un
secteur géographique qui a porté
la qualité de ses productions agricoles
avec des produits de grande qualité avec
une zone géographique qui fournit l'eau
du bassin de la de la Garonne avec une
participation développement durable très
forte à travers l'ensemble du
développement éolien qui est intervenu
sur nos hauteurs nous avons même nos
éleveurs sont même confrontés maintenant
la présence du loup donc nous sommes sur
un secteur géographique qui a le
sentiment d'apporter beaucoup à la
qualité environnementale et donc
apportant beaucoup à la qualité
environnementale de notre pays il me
semble raisonnable de permettre aussi à
cette population de pouvoir réaliser de
pouvoir réaliser ces possibilités
entendez bien que c'est une population
qui a souffert qui a connu la
désindustries qui connaît ses capacités
et qui a besoin de pouvoir les valoriser
en fait le temps demande à pouvoir se
développer comme les autres départements
de notre pays dans le respect de nos
engagements internationaux aucune
difficulté là-dessus justement Thomas
dessus vous le disait c'était pas le
seul projet contesté cette autoroute
entre Castres et Toulouse il y a
d'autres chantiers qui posent problème
absolument rien il y a plusieurs projets
autoroutiques sont pointés du doigt par
des collectifs et des associations avec
ce climat de tension certains d'entre
eux ont même été remis sur la table
depuis janvier par le ministre des
Transports Clément bon alors parmi
lesquels le contournement de Rouen vous
l'évoquiez la liaison à 154 à 120 entre
l'heure et l'heure et Loire là 114 412
pardon à Haute-Savoie l'élargissement de
l'autoroute sud de Bordeaux et bien
d'autres une cinquantaine au total des
projets pour qui pour les opposants ont
été pensés dans beaucoup de cas il y a
plusieurs décennies ne sont plus en face
en phase avec l'urgence climatique
d'aujourd'hui alors le ministre des
Transports a promis de tous les analyser
d'apporter des réponses d'ici l'été il
est même allé plus loin Clément bon
effectivement il va les analyser puis il
dit nous reverrons un certain nombre de
projets nous prendrons des décisions
courageuses audacieuses dans les
certains projets seront sans doute
suspendus ou mis à l'arrêt comment vous
accueillez ces déclarations du ministre
avec beaucoup de doutes puisque on voit
bien que dès qu'il faut prendre une
décision ils se retrouvèrent les
contrats qui ont été déjà été signés
vous prenez l'exemple de Rouen à Rouen
le maire de Rouen la métropole de Rouen
s'oppose au projet de contournement
c'est la région qui veut le financer et
l'imposer donc on est aussi des
contradictions sur un certain nombre de
territoires je vois quand même prendre
deux exemples le Pays de Galles et les
Pays-Bas on dit moratoire surtout nos
projets autoroutiers on arrête et on
regarde comment on améliore tout ça ou
comment on arrête purement et simplement
des projets c'est cette logique là qu'il
faut pas pour mettre un coup d'arrêt
économique mais pour mettre un coup
d'accélérateur sur la transition et la
réflexion sur les alternatives ces modes
de développement économique ne
fonctionnent plus et ne désenclave pas
les territoires encore une fois
ce que vous décrivez c'était les mêmes
arguments qu'on avait de Saint- qui
pareil a connu un passé industriel
important et se sentait déclassé et donc
avait besoin d'une nouvelle autoroute
entre Lyon et Saint-Étienne et ben ce
projet a été arrêté et Saint-Étienne
n'est pas devenu un désert économique et
ses développé et continuer de se
développer aussi donc il faut repenser
tous ces projets là il faut mettre un
coup d'arrêt et un bifurcation plus
radicale c'est ce que nous disent tous
les scientifiques en termes de
développement pour nos territoires la
notion la notion de moratoire est un et
typique de territoires riches pourvu de
tout ce qui est nécessaire nous redisant
simplement que dans le Tarn nous avons
retard important des équipements publics
que nous avons besoin d'être des
enclavés dans une région
c'est pas du tout anachronique et à un
moment donné il faut quand même correct
avec les gens plus les projets mettent
du temps à être réalisés il faut faire
toutes les enquêtes publiques il faut
gérer l'ensemble des contentieux dire
ensuite mais parce que le projet a duré
il est forcément anachronique c'est nier
l'ensemble du processus d'études de de
débats d'enquête de décision de décision
je suis je trouve l'argument vraiment
trop trop facile et inexactes
comment on peut comprendre cette
déclaration de Clément Baule sur les
projets dont tu as parlé Mathias le
gouvernement met un peu le pied sur le
frein oui je pense que là encore le
traumatisme de sainte Soline et le côté
un peu plus offensif du mouvement
écologiste le tournant plus offensive du
mouvement écologiste doit être dans les
esprits voilà les soulèvements de la
terre d'ailleurs juste après la
manifestation contre l'autoroute à 69
Toulouse Castres ont déclaré que s'il
n'était pas entendu s'il n'était pas si
les associations n'étaient pas reçues il
allait vers voilà ils allaient hausser
le ton et peut-être se tourner vers des
actions plus dures plus radicales
éventuellement du sabotage donc je pense
que si les pouvoirs publics ne pas
continuer dans cette espèce de marche en
avant de surdité absolue du côté des
contestations parce que sinon on va on
va se heurter à des mouvements
particulièrement violents c'est encore
possible aujourd'hui de faire de tels
projets dans le pays c'est pas c'est pas
à moi de donner mon avis mais ce qui est
ce qui est sûr c'est que en tout cas les
associations aujourd'hui écologistes et
les mouvements militants comme les
soulèvement de la terre extinction
rébellion et autres n'entendent
évidemment pas céder de ce côté-là parce
que on est dans un contexte d'urgence
climatique il nous reste très peu de
temps pour agir donc évidemment que des
projets qui ont été créés pensés il y a
40 ans ne sont plus ne sont plus à jour
aujourd'hui
non mais voilà moi je pense que on est
sur des schémas anciens et que on doit
repasser à à se tourner vers l'avenir et
c'est l'avenir n'est pas dans le
développement d'autoroute c'est plus
cette ce mode de développement ne
fonctionne plus
je ne crois pas que la démocratie soit
un schéma ancien je pense qu'il y a des
processus de décision dans d'autres pays
qui ont été respectés et qui doivent
maintenant permettre de mener à bien les
projets qui ont été décidées concertés
étudiés et décider avec un soutien très
fort des populations on
a compris au départ si vous voulez bien
vous restez avec nous on va regarder
ensemble ce qu'elle a une de nos
quotidiens région de ce matin
[Musique]
ce mercredi la question des violences en
marche des cortèges occupe la presse
régionale dont la vôtre Thomas dessus
oui le Black Bloc est constitué
d'assassins potentielles voilà les mots
forts retenus par Le Progrès de Lyon de
son interview de ce matin avec la
préfète de la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes
un millier de Black Blocs provoquant le
chaos sur le parcours de la
manifestation ce qui amène aussi la
Dépêche du Midi à s'interroger comment
en finir avec les casseurs le journal
toulousain reprend les termes de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne en
parlant de nouveaux paliers franchis
dans la violence et les questions qui en
découlent sur l'efficacité du maintien
de l'ordre à la française voilà au deux
jours de régionaux Philippe bonnecarer
et Thomas Doci sont à l'unisson on parle
piscine privée Mathias oui alors que
l'eau se fait de plus en plus rare
plusieurs départements de France voit le
nombre de piscines privées augmentées
c'est le cas en Corrèze ou dans les
roues par exemple comme le souligne la
montagne et Midi Libre une gestion de ce
bien commun qui doit nous interpeller
collectivement comme l'explique Fabienne
Watteau directrice de recherche au CNRS
dans le quotidien Montpellier 1 elle
avance des pistes à creuser comme une
tarification différenciée pour remplir
sa piscine sud-ouest nous parle de la
forêt du futur on a un dossier qui fait
écho à une mission d'information
alarmante de l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'adaptation de la forêt au changement
climatique maintient des grands
équilibres naturels exploitations
durables quelles essences également pour
l'avenir le journal donne la parole à la
députée du bassin d'Arcachon Sophie
panenac le rapporteuse de la mission
d'information pour évoquer les enjeux
des prochaines années et en parlant des
prochaines années la question de
l'immobilier interroge la presse
régionale les prix de l'immobilier sont
en baisse pratiquement partout sur le
territoire 5% de chutes en un an sur
l'ancien à Paris donc dans la majorité
des villes moyennes aussi et pour cause
emprunter coûte de plus en plus cher les
prêts sont de plus en plus difficiles à
obtenir également bref un marché à la
peine le ministre du Logement Olivier
Klein devrait en ce sens se faire des
annonces mardi prochain on termine par
une autre alerte oui est-ce que certains
d'entre vous sont allergiques aux pollen
autour de cette table oui alors il
faudra éviter de se rendre dans le Var
comme dix autres départements un peu
partout en France le Var est en risque
élevé d'allergie au pollen en pleine
période de floraison évidemment c'est un
véritable festival écoulement nasal
éternuement maux de tête et je vous en
passe des meilleurs il existe des
traitements efficaces si vous en
souffrez vous pouvez vous rapprocher de
votre aide
merci
Philippe bonne Carrère merci Thomas
dossier d'avoir
interface merci beaucoup je remonte
votre livre l'affrontement qui vient de
l'écho résistance à l'écho terrorisme
c'est à dire merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'avoir été avec nous merci
Mathias merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
si vous voulez voir revoir cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre nouvelle
plateforme publique senna.fr prochain
rendez-vous à 18h sans ce public Thomas
Hugues à 15h la séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement et puis on
se retrouve demain notre invité Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe les
républicains au Sénat très bonne journée
à demain
[Musique]